and men are pretty good at taking care
of children know their I would say
they're not as good at taking care of
infants as women are because they don't
have the full range of resources at hand
and they're not I don't think they're
they I don't think they have the same
kind of immediate intuitive
understanding of or attraction to babies
that men have I think that switches
around the age of two or two-and-a-half
when the kids can engage in
rough-and-tumble play because men are
much more likely to engage in
rough-and-tumble play with children than
women are and rough-and-tumble play
seems to be one of the things that
civilize is children and it's partly
because you know one of the things that
you have to learn when you're a child is
what actually hurts you and what can be
ignored
and what actually hurts someone else and
what can be ignored and the best way to
learn that is in rough-and-tumble play
because what happens is that if you
playing with a kid they get more and
more excited than they do more and more
crazy things until they do something
that either hurts them or hurts you and
then you have to say look you know
that's you can't do that and it's like a
dance in a sense you know when you're
wrestling with a little kid and you have
to let them win very frequently because
otherwise they don't they don't continue
the game and you can tell that because
if they're if the game is going well
they're laughing with insane delight
because kids just love rough-and-tumble
play you know and they love crazy things
I mean you can throw them in the air and
catch them and they think that's just
great you know and but partly what
you're doing is you're extending their
body in all sorts of ways and getting
them to learn in an embodied sense where
the limits of that where their limits
are and where the limits of other people
are and that's embodied and children who
haven't have that man they're just so
awkward it's unbelievable you know they
might have some hypothetical sense of
how to interact with another person but
they don't have an embodied sense of it
and they can't tell the difference
between what hurts them and what doesn't
you know because often a young child if
they're startled they'll start to cry
and then you can say well you know that
didn't hurt and then they'll notice oh
yeah that didn't hurt and they'll stop
crying
but if they haven't had their limits
tested they'll cry and anything
unexpected even if it doesn't hurt and
that's not good because if you cry under
all conditions the probability that
you'll make friends when you're three is
like zero
because another kid will start playing
with you and maybe play rock and if you
burst into tears you know several times
the first the kids just going to go
somewhere else and find a different play
mate you know they'll say you're just a
baby